so it looked pretty crazy in New York
yesterday of course looking crazy was
the whole point of this to terrify swing
voters into never voting for Donald
Trump what was it like well
congresswoman Marjorie Taylor green of
Georgia was there for the arraignment
before she arrived the mayor of the city
already failed just a year into office
Eric Adams described her as a criminal
and implied he would punish her if she
misbehaved
meanwhile actual lunatics showed up and
prevented her from speaking watch
so can I ask what those are for
um so we hear that Marjorie Taylor green
is coming to the city
um right here so we brought some
whistles to hand out to people to drown
her out with some noise
[Applause]
[Music]
that's a sitting member an elected
member of the Congress everyone can see
where this is going merger Taylor Green
joins us tonight to recount what she saw
in New York yesterday Congressman thanks
so much for coming on what was that like
well it was absolute chaos and that's
what the mayor of New York City wanted
to happen to me you see he threatened me
and basically basically put out a dog
whistle for violence against me and then
there was a funded text alert that went
out naming me by name and telling people
to do exactly what that man was doing
hand out whistles and try to create a
chaotic scene of violence and assault
and that's against the law by the way
Tucker you see they didn't want me to be
able to protest and use my first
amendment rights and they wanted
violence I think they wanted that to
happen because they want to repeat
January 6 all over again they want all
of us Trump supporters Maga basically
Republicans and just good Americans to
look like criminals and that's what they
do in communist countries and that's
actually what we're seeing today well
the first thing to do of course is take
away your freedom to speak and if you
can't say what you really think then
you're not a free person you're a slave
and once you are then there's really not
nothing they can't do to you I do you
think people understand the implications
of not allowing someone to speak
I I don't think they do I don't think
people realize what dangerous times
we're living in you see the Democrat
Party they're the fascists they want to
cancel our voices they want to censor us
and they want to completely Force us
into complying you see the reason why
they're Prosecuting or should we say
persecuting Donald Trump is for the
crime of actually winning the 2016
presidential election that's what
they're in hysterics over and they've
never gotten over it but what they
really want to do is once they remove
their top political opponent which is
President Trump they're going to come
after all of us this has happened
repeatedly throughout history and people
need to wake up to the reality of the
danger we're living in really quick
since you were just there but mayor
Adams described New York as quote his
home how did his home look pretty neat
and tidy
no his home is disgusting I compared it
to what I called Gotham City the streets
are filthy they're covered with people
basically dying on drugs they can't even
stand up they're falling over there's so
much crime in the city I can't I can't
comprehend how people live there it was
repulsive it smells bad and I just I
think it's a terrible place
yeah with some nice people I will say
that congresswoman Marjorie Taylor green
just back from New York thank you so
much
thank you Tucker subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
Tucker Carlson tonight